je suis allé chez les flics mais qu'est
ce qui te prend été complètement malade
ou quoi j'en peux plus de cette vie de
merde mais c'est vous qui va vous voulu
cette vie d'accord c'est nous qui avons
mûri mais qu'est ce qu'on a voulu on
avait 7 et 8 ans dis-moi ce qu'on
choisit quand on a 7 et 8 ans à
l'invention de lumière
encore pour contout
thériault que ça une autre maison faut
vous êtes ma vue des jeux voltaire
l'app l'horaire d'argent juste les amène
aussi à la présidence maintenant des
vrais indiens tués
ah que
nous marcherons dans la nature voyez
quelque chose de caresser
est-ce que tout et rend tout fclm blank
inventé le carré
quand on n'a pas les pieds à l'école
parce que l'école c'est ici
l'école c'est obligatoire c'est la loi
et toi tu es hors la loi
nora j'apprends ce jour que j'ai été
condamné à deux ans de prison et des
chutes de tous mes droits parentaux et
tu dois savoir que ça me changerait les
conditions pour refaire surface que
toutes les poursuites contre moi et
contre eux soit interrompu dans le cas
inverse ne resteront cachés jusqu'à la
majorité des enfants accourent